друзі вітаю всіх усім доброго вечора у
Дена по 8 вечора це означає завтра і в
ефірі платформа та масивними піт ринку
міністерство з цією наукою України і я і
модератор володимир страшенно вітаю вас
класно ми продовжуємо з вами розмовляє з
будинком та українцями щось fohow але
психологом ще готовий акс бригад і
адекватні масивний stan vs їх треба у
бочках умовах та
ну сьогодні ми запустили дуже вдома
кохання ну дуже класного пахового
психологів та world cup of when you
психолого провідним лікарем сонячник
наукою праву частину в музейних батек
проектів як експерт-психолог
його рогатою у вас харчувалася заради бочки
літаючих класний porsche захід вони та
ким ми задаємо у наших гостей він трахкає
не впіймати і нестабільність червоний
відсотка кашубіну для всіх нас стало ну
стоїть сотні шоком і
батут нас не вчи коли з чого починається
і он відкривай вже весь інтернет там 9
пісні прийшов ось я у вас ти весь
інтернет залі що ви буваєте але якусі
харизма захисту ж не був у Києві
ночувала в підвалах але якусі мишкам
сіквелів тієї години
курять земної було двоє моїх дітей zynga
achires ти вже виїхав та поїхали у
бік західної України за суміші вже
робін і тут я грізні я хочу я волонтер
я
командую я випадково випадково на марс про
цій фірмі багатств та саяку всіх до
слова так само як і вусик але
ось владна пупсик ми починала проводять
ефір з одного дня провини здається і нам
приходять захід ще намагаємося у людей
плисти і дізнається про ми так по металу для
себе що пройшло де кирико фас ну цеху
логічно втомлюся людей вид спочатку
повного шовку куди back to her butt це
моя я не знаю що я потім віку стаки мій
борг і топ то сьогодні ми там же завтра
перехожому такий стан завтра стануть усі
пропало треба бігти після завтра ще й
кристан тільки припустимо а за раз я
пам'ятаю такий порт
soho логічно дорога але тільки люди у тому
план сексу
викладав 1 казань чого бог уже на
стрибну якутськ так ось так і стану я на
паху та психолог точний колір тут waves
просто режим скажіть blass couture
правильніше почати повторювати ж нічим уже
шість ниток не буває у козерогів тихого
видами
розумієте людину дуже особливу
творіння і ми все-таки діємо по
певну закономірність
наша реакція перша реакція
автоматичне від емоційних вона
відбувається на те, що відбувається навколо
нас є будь-яка подія яка є
викликає у нас емоцію мені змінюється середа
навколо нас змінюється інформаційне тло
з'являється нола емоцій, а тому на
зараз такі сильні перепади, бо
якщо щось сталося допустимо хорошим і
дізналися це з наших близьких безпеки
або ми змогли допомогти комусь на стіл
піднімається потім і знову дізналися про тих
жахливих речей, які відбуваються в нашій
реальністю фон йде вниз тому даний
момент у тебе погане тлумачення нами
ночі вона обов'язково буде і
люди які зрозуміють що емоції
автоматично вмикається на постійно
мінливі події їм легше буде
переносити нестабільне свого
психологічного стану
то c нормально прабатьківщині рація коханим і
моїм і прийняти
якщо ви реагуватимете по-іншому
значить це новий представники роду
людського
відразу мило а не може така ціна пустимо
анна пругова кракатау крижані без
штурвал і всі отримані факти, наприклад
там приходять депресію
1100 на чиєму серці може потрібний ніби
річки нас таки потрібен
почнемо з того, що навколо нас і ми в тому
числа до ресурсу тобто у нас все має
обмежений термін дії за все
ресурсу ресурс він не нескінченний book
туса ми як ресурс теж не нескінченний і
ресурс наших емоційних сил наших
можливостей справлятися з тривогою теж
не нескінченний тому якщо ми знаходимося
у постійному стані напруга не
знаходити чи не прикладай зусилля щоб
якось втекти втекти кудись де ми
можемо перепочити як ресурс ну
просто припинимо своє існування
організм почне відключатися тому що
наш організм до кінця боротиметься за
нас своїми дивними шляхами і тому він
йде на стан апатії депресії щоб
таким чином а блідих тому ми можемо
або очолити цей процес тобто
визнаючи що ми хочемо все зробити для
нашої перемоги, але ми як ресурс необхідний
потребує відпочинку ми собі води або
просто прийде почуття апатії депресії та
вона очолить нас тут все-таки
вигаданими безодня відблиск і наша психіка
сама робот для нашора вивчаємо два
способу заповнення ресурсу це або
відпочинок або пріорітизації його
використання
сюди пріорітизації його навколо будівлі за
раз я така досить популярна історія
з урахуванням про топтали докази на шляху
наприклад люди на виїхала там на
західну україну обидва за крутою
біт іншу і викладаю фотографії що вона
дасть їм гарне місце там знаю пташки
співають квіточки ростуть і люди пишіть явка
можеш там такого квадрата як ти можеш
там бла-бла-бла за розпинаючи та ну так
тут cc face в інтернеті приблизно пусти
ну і люди починають у чогось більше за тебе
мають рацію але всі роботи з такими шляхами мають рацію
але я кину нас продажів ночами викладка у
нас точка зору поєдинку людям
як я сказав позначити емоції вона
виникає автоматично і все одно ми
як люди ми хочемо подобатися іншим і
нікуди від цього не дінешся тому
будь-яка негативна реакція навіть у людини
який на телебаченні роками каже він
до всього звик все одно вона викликають у
йому в нього реакцію тому ви коли
отримуєте негативний відгук на якесь
своє дійство ви не можете не відчувати
якусь образу навіть на те, що на як
замінюватися або погано я взагалі погано
нічого не хотів і тут дуже допомагає
допомагає усвідомленість людина коли ви
знаєте що там де б ви не знаходилися
ви намагаєтеся в magic своїх ресурсів
прогноз це quoris вам буде легше
приносячи переносити негативну реакцію
яка може бути в інших людей тому
що вони просто втомилися тому що це
негативна реакція їхня можливість
знаєте через трохи клапанів тому
що вони набагато гірші ситуації тому
ось це ось усвідомленість розуміючи ті речі
що я сказав допоможе легше переносити
неминучі вчинки інших людей які
не пов'язані з нашим бажанням подобатися
акцію судом його нести у собі розвиватися
є три питання які автоматично
вводить людину в усвідомлений стан
просто яка моя мета як тільки ви
поставили це питання і на нього відповідаєте
ви вже перейшли з несвідомого
стан та стан де вами керують
ваші звички з минулого на базі ваших
страхів та комплексів ви переходите в
стан моменту усвідомлений стан
цей стан
поведінки у мамі питання яка моя мета
автоматично переводить вас у свідоме
стан друге питання яка моя вигода
знову відповідь на це запитання автоматично
переводить вас в свідомий стан і
третє питання які варіанти дій
наближають мене до досягнення моєї мети
тобто якщо у вас є лише один
варіант дій ви не в свідомому
стані
якщо у вас більше ніж один два три
чотири готові перебуваєте в свідомому
стан те, що в реальності завжди
більше, ніж вони говорять
так небезпечно саморефлексії на мою думку
дроти т.к. левичева та чоловік людина
боїться вовни наша мотивація до сну, але я
всі ми хочемо ще в наші комплекси та наші
страхи номінали потрібно роботи
вдома і став ще може бути лише два
стану досьє думати
ось ми можемо вузлам і до того ж і страху повік
що ми назвали укласти, а вже дано навіть
бовтали д за розгойдує страх ну відразу
милі перед
за свої жити, а щоб його розуміємо дуже
сильно там продовжити обстріли на видатних
місцях яким поважав і раніше безтурботними
avenged та кам'яні так та страх полонений
за мої будні батах витрати на роботу
бізнес і ну які по бутові мови там
буде на xxviii я ціную страхом проти те
чим можна і вояку не менше, ніж можна
знову тут все напевно почнеться з
внутрішнього діалогу самим із собою
зрозумієте будь-яку дію будь-яка емоція вона
приймається не в моменті коли ви
здійснювати вона приймається на базі
переконань які у вас є
Іра близьким ми хочемо вплинути на своє
поведінка тут взагалі нам треба
працювати з нашими переконаннями що означає
шлюб нами і тому тут ось боротьбі
склад треба і бека заварювати собою в
плані скажи смуг на даний момент
яка твоя основна мета який пилосос
треба
коли є форс-мажор на та стані
війна це найсильніший клас мажор
котрий може бути не довго граючий
тому що план це наявність стабільності
війна передбачає нестабільність по
своїм фактом тому введення собі в
короткої граючі цілі розмова з собою
погоду того яка твоя мета зараз які
у тебе ресурси є година які у тебе
є і обмеження можливості той
момент, що знаходиться, перейшов з
одного етапів торгує абсурд той самий
питання яка зараз твоя мета які у
тебе зараз можливості раніше ніякої
тобі бажання таким чином ми легші
пройдемо через ось цю ось блага тут
повно які ми всі зараз
емоційний
це про короткі терміни планування
циски річки дейн ти ж місяць
вдало та ти ж якраз два
нових бачати я наказ змінити
заражу тебе наздожене горбачів ще їжі
на диві стабільніше наша база
репарація стабільно вища.
відразу хвилин і розвивати зараз ти
на те ми проводимо особливо я встану з
відома насті за допомогу та 3 5 біт
побачимо він їх таким чином починаємо
аналізу вата ситуацію та
історію накрутку терміналі плани на мага
і муся там взяти під контроль свої жити
а я комбо року нас аластер збиток
глобальному секс
це не зараз та на вигляд це просто
витратити ваші сили прийде кого
вчора такі види знаходяться в
ми зараз бату хто в нас же в цьому
завданнями диким гринишин живий на бо там
врахувати людей в обамі будинку пасивних
грали життя сім'ї та але її харизмою
аматі місцям і уде таких людей ми
собачі мудро туре 1000 у пошуком
золотий мутин ще спливає саме знають
вже сильно переживає щось начебто не в
складаєте сосунки через шляхи всі
страхи та переживання і так далі і їх
реакцію що можна зуби так готові щоб
клімат у руди не buff більше здоровий за
раз
я вам зараз скажу незвичну річ але
вона буде чесно їсти взагалі три способи
взаємодії своїм із цим століття перші
два дісталися нам від тварин ранів ми
або боремося із проблемою яка є
припустимо ми переконуємо людину поводитися
тому що ми хочемо або ми лан ми тікаємо
перестаємо спілкуватися людина яка треба
мені приємний чи низ третій спосіб
який з'явився в ході еволюції наші з
вмінням нашим розмовляти це будь-яке
дія яка відрізняється lan і я його
називають петляючий тобто ми використовували
будь-який інструмент що допомагає у
даної ситуації зменшити градус на
інші тому, що від близьких ми не можемо
ми не хочемо їх перемагати добивати зараз
коли багато людей виявляться заходу
простір я тиждень жив на заході
просторі я знаю що не можна втекти
з бомбосховища
знаходишся і чи від арти провести
обстріл і так ти починаєш петляти ти
робиш вигляд що ти спиш чи ти
починаєш сказати розповісти казку дитині
це готуємо важче з тобою спілкуватися
промовляєш собі певні речі то
є ти шукаєш варіант полегшити своє
стан з урахуванням визнання інших
але теж перебувають під напругою і
тепер ось цей зашморг не за знаходженням
балансу між своїм бажанням майже не
тільки вас
сподіваюся я
походу ми такі до знайома
роком та церквою варіанти як можна
ситуації
баланс
дає можливість
до 100 літрів з інтернет та точку стане
[музика]
я хотів сказати, що ми балансуємо
балансуємо toca toca
Усе
так
[музика]
адреси позовом видувається війну forever
молодим 212 що вони дзвонить
так у нас тут по вітрина vetrina тривога
і сам уже в платі на інтернет трохи за
буквально інтернет знаю так так багато
процедур історія була
такий годинник
але так
люттю
абсент я супер супер супер супер ось я
такий термін синдром накладного жити
хулі ти домагаєшся повний ще буду
пісня то ви їх ми там пари може
саду пункти
в бюро бізнес та та адекватною станцію я
вам точно можу сказати, що так допоможе і
тобто будь-які не забудете зафіксувати
свої бажання вас є і яка зараз
середовище не дає можливість реалізувати те
є ви себе скажіть от коли
закінчиться зараз форс-мажор я не забуду
що я хотів подзвонити каву до неї
додзвонитися я не забуду поїхати на
риболовлею оскільки майже з вудками я не
забуду також я себе пообіцяв, що я буду
щодня чи там щомісяця
приїжджати до мами вагітність я не
забуду що я пообіцяв що я
нарешті вивчу англійську
тобто ось не забудьте ті бажання що
ви зараз кажете як що вони
реалізуються коли закінчиться ось це
постарайтеся постаратися
в принципі відсоток
раз пробував чи відра льону стиву на
Ну нормально . золотом у нашу психіку
так нікому ми йому але в плані у плані
фіксації своїх бійці у смутку до радості
колір та ще за раз наших божих ми не
можемо кричали зуби там ще такий годинник
самі
розумієте великим розвалити зараз я
буду секунду хочу сказати що є
дві категорії людей категорія людей у
яких ідеалістична складова
велика та категоріях дев яких якщо
містична складова різниця між
діаліз там реалістом у тому що ідеаліст
на перше місце ставить свою ж кутами він
не враховує фактор ситуації фактів
обмежень які на жаль але в
цьому світі що ми живемо де має
більше в ямі
реаліст враховуватиме всі три фактори
визнає середовище що ситуація обмеження
на шкоду моє бажання але він не забуде
просте бажання колись зміниться
зміниться ситуація він його тоді
реалізує
важка бути реалістами токто
класно класно сказано це як
овочі ви значення на чиюсь всьому ідеали
та ідеалісти та всі ми думаємо про свої
обожнювання
верхові фактори ось дуже
супер так впоратися суперова аллен
друзі називають з він помри цю тобі миші
так і inside можна винести
яскравість батьківщину та
обожнюванням he will then кістки з небезпекою
там вивчаємо
ось сюди проекції собака собою щоб по
металу персі там пару також не можемо
місяць нас
говорила про те, що українці за раз
повільніше за неї її реально не було
докази кущам у тих улюблених історій у
фейсбуках хто кому там гетьман хто хто
кому корупціонер ну ви розумієте прощаю
хто такий нинішніх чувак скажемо так
зарости всередині нічого розвивалася
effects з кожного дня є у
найсильнішою приводів їм сидиш з .
зоря цеховий чуму колір було чому
поцілунки давання абсолютного там вискочила
в Україні на місяць тому ж основу
довелося
цікавого чи відповісти у нас є
характеристику кожної людини є
індивідуальних через
що з'явився
чи може існувати разом антилопа та
крокодил
ну-но водоспаду буду на магате
він допоможе, але вони можуть тільки в одному
моменті коли є загальна небезпека вони
беруть від а ось коли не бив до пожежі
внести беру навіть може допомагати буду
іншому але щойно закінчується
фактом між небезпека вони знову
починають виявляти ті якості, які
відрізняють їх один від одного тому зараз
і людей, які під впливом небезпеки
щоб вижити об'єдналися зараз знову
небезпека ось це безпосередньо йде
та їх особисті особливості комплексу та все
решта піднімається там на поверхню
напій з
болотом може або йти на болоті хвиля
може якщо це величезна цегла якимось
якийсь час там там кілька хвилин
хвиля може бути
розумів це мовляв але лібери du blog відразу
мили що за 1 фух можна видихнути то
потрібно поворот осад і його, але в принципі
жити а повернулася в нормальне русло
без менше можна займатися тим, чим я
хочу люблю займатися
друзі це для треба так за трояндочки
нікуди не пішла у нас слуху не треба
розбив
я така така історія і за роздружитися
популярний захід у психологічних
пабликах та до волонтерських груп акція
робота з травмою
сірки та робота з травми вуличні подали
скаже бидло скачі не у нас шанс у нас я
моя новина в українців
стати націю я повністю томура одруженим
синдромом гострому ти що
це обов'язково буде
проблемою насущним питанням для
ось коли закінчиться ця проклята війна
і ми почнемо
розбирати завали та
психологічні завали в тому числі
тому що ми всі пережили травму
деякі люди принесли
феноменально сильну траву і тому
безумовно
травматизація населення у світі
драматизації я консультую людей
які
мають
вплив на прийняття рішень я знаю що
що зараз вже порушується питання про те
як ми допомагатимемо людям після того
як вони виживуть як ми допомагатимемо їм
адаптуватися ось цим страшним
психологічним бравим
у нас слава богу є спеціалісти
трохи але у нас є
психологічний інститут який
займається цим питанням і готують
фахівців я знаю що є вже
консультації зі сторонами де де той же
євро чи де є вже виробленою
методики роботи з людьми які
пережили чи такі події тому
що сама ця проблема вона обов'язково
буде нам нікуди не дінеться результат
відкладеної травми він буде
на знімку масовий може особи програма
розумійте тут просто питання наскільки
вона масово буде у сильному прояві
якесь
реакція будівлі що ряд подій
ось уже залежно від інших
факторів вранці умовно темпераменту від
оточення які у людини від неї там
психічної лабільності або шляху купі
інших факторів залежить як у конкретно
у його випадку відбуватиметься ось це
ось переживання травми в якійсь формі
переживати і буде у всіх ви всі у нас у
більшості
це про такі на біш над і поза дротом і
у чому самовиражатися з . заворотом
жити а по виїмці людей ну так і їзда по
зонам вже про
апатія депресія
саморуйнування
[музика]
почуття провини
можливе покарання себе за те
що я не повівся там певним
тому що коли людина хороша коли
наречена моральні цінності
жаль почуття провини без різниці
реального чи придумане запускає
механізм компенсації у вигляді покарання
щоб залишатися хорошим треба собі
покарати причому не має значення
і ми можемо зіткнутися з цим елементом
що люди там які їхали тому що
діти приїжджатимуть я не буду
почуватися винними це може
виявлятися
багато може бути різних проблем
деякі
тривожні розлади та ліцензовані
ну москва kr масаж
відразу міф топ то для пом'яті багаті
фільмів про там американських ризикових на
американських фільмів cool це вона
прийшла зміїні там за хітом я б новата
бла-бла-бла в
будь-якому в такому в такому
худа
я ж вчився в Америці довго прожив там
би торкнутися України 2004 року, коли
були 1 знаменною звільнилося
перша наша революція та
я досі спілкуюсь з сільським не вчився
хто зараз роботи з тієї ж
спеціальності що я і ми постійно
обговорюємо ось цей момент що як
як підготуватися та як
налаштовується на те щоб полегшити
людям переживань ось це
посттравматичних аспектів які
які американці вони мають досвід з
поверненням своїх солдатів кістках воїн
якому не бере участі вони не мають такої
досвід уже з роботою з мирним населенням
тому що на їхній території не було
такий страшного так вони пензель вже за
побіжимо крики ми можемо у за раз заросла
простого щось замахиться вина відкриває
готові ще менше знаєш з чого так
насадки для собак
так дивіться тут означає як я вже сказав
емоція виникає як соматична
реакція на те, що відбувається тобто
почуття страху гніву роздратування будь-яка
інша емоція не питає дозволу
щоб спасти на думку ми не можемо
контролювати звалюємо зусилля
зненавидимо від цього але будь-яку дію
послаблює силу та mods
тобто дія коли я особливо
усвідомлено і неусвідомлено якщо вона
не дуже
усвідомлена дія переклад себе в
момент коли ви зафіксували що у вас
є 1 3 бога або якась давай сильне
почуття перекладу а усвідомлено
діяти я починаю мити підлогу не
починай голову починаю шкарпетки
газу тобто переведення в якусь дію
яке я ініціюю abyss
зменшити силу емоцій не прибере її
повністю але менше дія послаблює
силу емоції це знову факти на цьому
факті побудовано прояв спортивних
клубів саме на цьому факті збудовано
пам'ятайте фільм форест гамп білка коли він
у нього були його особисті проблеми, він бігав
дія послаблюється посміхатися тому
ініціюйте дії усвідомлено
дієвому менше тут тривогу яку
ми не можемо зараз дещо
support up to моя дружина пробрало
квартиру три години ночі
добрик баранів у принципі нагадуючи
дівич-вечорі, у нас була б для дачі на
прогноз але мені історіям з вас уже
розгорнув її китай буде за нас
українців і хотів би прямо папус це
вас обожнення вислав тобі всіх нас щоб
котила по божаться нашим передача або
українці це я вже
і я у своїх відео басейн опинюся у мене
було чесно пула до кожного українця за
розтинає домострою своїми личинками
акту своїм дітям будь-кого до краєм нам там
чин вікна так часто до залу і знайду будь-які
те чи це скільки риби до кінця з
видом робота для ось я та раз не знаю
людей ці бджоли celeb не рубав ще для
соніка там ще ванни хоче доплати
рядками тому я хочу потиснути вам терпіння
хоче потиснути вам свої цінності
забувають ще зростуть і раз острови
натирка ви коростово я поповнив а там
вже і наші його надовго на б стати цифра
там вузла ущербний виріб
слава героям слава навіть вам яскраву
затягнув роботи затягну сьогодні доучився
до нас я на адже ми batoost їм спокійно
сяк зрозуміє і сьогодні для мене душить
сильно буде або оправі ківагор його
на приклад відкрити обвал переведений з
та best on us відома насті буда буда курей
залишатися саякою спіймано всі наші коли
читаєш так що дякую вам ще раз її
успіхи у виправлять eat you want ya que
затікає, ми або біжить прямо за
вистукує фелан іспит друзі з
великим вуса завтра іспит мирну ніч